[Music]
we want to share a powerful story about
giving back this Thanksgiving in
war-torn Ukraine Slava medvedenko is a
former basketball star and winner of two
NBA championships in his time with the
Los Angeles Lakers when Russia invaded
his home country he picked up a gun like
so many ukrainians but once lava saw the
impact of the war on Ukraine's youth he
sold his prize Championship ranks he
used the money to provide counseling and
sports opportunities to kids Chris
livesay has his story
Slava medvedenko ascended to the highest
Heights of basketball winning
back-to-back NBA championships alongside
Shaquille O'Neal and Kobe Bryant for the
LA Lakers
but of his millions of fans none matter
more than the ones back home in key
like him
in a war zone
but for one Blissful moment the war is
interrupted by new basketballs from the
LA Lakers in the game they love they
kind of forget that that's a war that's
like emotional relax to them and therapy
until suddenly
the War I was barging in they United
they together they play here we go
lighters go off that's it there's no
more light no more life
wow
but they're still playing with their
basically some flashlights and some cell
phone lights yeah yeah amazing with his
Nation Under Siege Slava put down his
ball and picked up a rifle I make
decision uh not to stay in Kiev whatever
I can do to defend my city
what did you see we see cars they
shooting with the like bullet holes in
the cars and it's a dead bodied inside
that cars dead bodies dead bodies yeah
and and I saw that people just lay down
on the side on the road
and these are your people yeah yeah it
is and on the cars there was like big
sign it's like children inside
but the Russians still should shoot that
cars you have kids how did that feel
that was scary
it was then he understood what really
matters in life people not possessions
not even his prize championship rings
what good are they he wondered if
something happens to me I'm start
thinking about that and make decision I
have to sell on my rings and then help
my country so we put them up for auction
online he hoped they'd sell for six
figures together instead each of them
did netting more than a quarter of a
million dollars a record I think that's
good we can spend more money on the kids
and help more kids this is where all the
shrap repairing School windows and it
shattered the windows yeah
and school basketball courts destroyed
by Russian Artillery
and sending kids to basketball camps he
played alongside Kobe Bryant Shaquille
O'Neal you won two championships what
are you more proud of
that time with the NBA or your time now
helping with these kids you know it's a
two different worlds like NBA I was
young that was my dream to play in the
best league in the world
uh now I'm more a matcher and uh
I think different I think
to help my country it's more important
and today what's your dream
my dream to get Ukraine and free wealthy
and independent
for CBS mornings Chris livesay he talk
about sacrifice yeah you know the things
that you might think are important he
could be here right living his life safe
and sound but he's back home trying to
help others and the things that perhaps
might seem on the surface to matter
don't matter as much when you're facing
life and he's reminding those kids they
have something to live for a future they
can build and change really remarkable
it's so hard to think of just you know
why why they're in this situation begin
with